silence quant à lui l'a fait devant les
interventions policières qui est ce soir
ici à québec l'a alors que les
manifestants et si cette diversité
d'ailleurs les autobus sont fait
reprendre littéralement sociale d'un
côté comme de l'autre
alors que le rassemblement se déroulait
très bien et eu aussi beaucoup de
violence le policière notamment une
manifestante qui était blessé au visage
par une canette lacrymogènes
les policiers ont déclaré les
manifestations illégales ont demandé à
plusieurs reprises aux manifestants de
sortir pourquoi il s'oppose bec et des
gens qui ont ainsi de sortir les gens
s'est dirigé vers la rue 1 à repasser en
fait pour aller vers l'extérieur puis un
magnet ont décidé de stopper en fait
laissé six ans le quittait et puis ils
ont aussi le de des deux côtés en fait
le mien souricière l'a littéralement
s'attendent à un moment donné on a senti
par contre que les manifestants avaient
l'intention prendre la roue vous avez
peut-être qu'il faut y avait une façon
de prendre la rue le tout dans tous les
cas en fait le lieu d'intervention assez
musclée des gaz lacrymogènes qui ont été
lancés j'ai occupé est une championne
avait reçu le même un caméraman tu veux
ton banquier des pauvres est lui même
puis on voit en fait là actuellement qui
est plus d'une centaine de personnes qui
sont pris le actuellement le don la
souricière avec les arrestations et en
ce moment aussi le si vraiment en fait
l'une des plus fortes est en revanche
glissèrent que j'ai vu le plus longtemps
leurs à québec m